- [Narrator] Brazil takes
breast milk very seriously.
It has over 200 milk banks nationwide,
the highest of any country.
But here's the weird part,
while the US has over
one and a half times the
population of Brazil,
it only has 24 milk banks,
which distribute less
than six million ounces
of breast milk a year.
And that's a serious problem,
since intensive care units
alone demand over 63
million ounces annually,
so parents of healthy babies
need to find another way
to feed their kids and will turn to other,
more obscure sources.
Of course, many parents
have a built-in supply
of breast milk, free of charge.
But not everyone can breastfeed.
This might be because
they don't produce enough
on their own, their work
schedule leaves little time
for breastfeeding, or they
simply don't have breasts
in the first place.
In fact, only an estimated
26% of North Americans
exclusively breastfed.
So if you're short on
breast milk, many parents
will head to groups like
Human Milk 4 Human Babies,
which connects milk
donors with milk seekers.
In this case, helping over
20,000 community members
in 52 countries.
But there's still not
enough milk to go around.
That's where online marketplaces come in.
On ad classified sites,
like Only The Breast,
and Breastfeeding Moms
Unite, people sell their milk
for around two dollars an ounce.
That's a bargain compared
to over four dollars
that milk banks will charge.
But this is a case of
you get what you pay for,
because the milk you might
receive may not be 100% human.
(cow mooing)
In a 2015 study for example,
researchers ordered milk
from an anonymous online market.
They tested the contents of
each sample and discovered
that one in every 10
samples was contaminated
with cow's milk, and by
a significant amount too.
The contaminated samples
contained about 10% cow's milk.
That's a lot more than a few drops.
Moreover, a 2013 report
found that 74% of milk
from online markets
contained harmful bacteria,
which probably came from
poor collection, storage,
or shipping.
All this begs the question,
why go through the hassle
and risk, when you can
easily grab some baby formula
at your local grocery?
Well, formula just doesn't cut it.
Human breast milk is jam-packed
with brain developing
nutrients, disease-fighting
antibodies that jump-start
the immune system, and
helpful bacteria that rev up
the babies own gut flora.
But baby formula has no
antibodies or bacteria
and that can make a huge difference.
Researches calculated that over 800,000
formula-fed infants who
die each year worldwide,
could have been saved by breastfeeding.
So parents are caught between
a rock and a hard place.
Formula or mystery milk?
Fun fact, in Brazil, the
government funds couriers
on motorbikes to collect
breast milk directly
from people's houses.
(clicking)